I WAS SCOFFED AT FOR SAYING
THAT.
THEY’RE NOT THE AMATEURS WHO
NANCY PELOSI TRIED TO BRUSH OFF
GREAT FOR JOINING ME NOW, KEVIN
McCARTHY BREAD CONGRESSMAN,
GIVING HER PAST ANTI-SEMITISM, A
DENIER OF AL QAEDA.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS VALUES?
>> IT TELLS A LOT BECAUSE OF
CONTRAST, HE’S IN MINNESOTA.
HERE IS BERNIE WILL PROMOTE
COMMUNIST CUBA, BUT HE WILL NOT
PRAISE ISRAEL.
WHO DOES HE WANT INTRODUCING
HIM?
ILHAN OMAR.
SHE INTRODUCED A BOYCOTT
SANCTION BILL AGAINST ISRAEL
THEMSELVES.
THAT SHOWS THAT NANCY PELOSI
FOLDED TO THESE SOCIALIST
FRESHMEN AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR.
DO YOU REMEMBER ONE AOC HAD A
MEETING WITH SPEAKER PELOSI?
SHE DIDN’T WEED OUT THE PICTURE,
NANCY PELOSI DID
SHE HAS TO COME.
>> Laura: TO SEE MY POINT IN
THE ANKLE TONIGHT?
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016.
THE PEOPLE WANTED ONE THING AND
A LOT OF THE DONORS WANTED
SOMETHING ELSE.
DONALD TRUMP SAID BASICALLY, I
WILL BEAT THE BUSHES, THE
OBAMA’S, MEDIA, HOLLYWOOD.
I THINK THEY’RE ALL DESTRUCTIVE.
HE CLEAR-CUT THE WHOLE FIELD.
THE REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
MODERATES.
HE IS BOLD AND HE HAS THE
ENERGY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN A PICKLE, A
REAL PICKLE.
>> HE DID IT WITH ONE-THIRD OF
THE MONEY THAT BLOOMBERG HAS
SPENT.
THANKS NO ONE TALKS ABOUT.
>> Laura: THERE WILL BE
PRESSURE ON BLOOMBERG, CORRECT?
>> OH, YEAH,.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE BEATING
BIDEN WOULD BE EASIER FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I DON’T KNOW WHERE THESE
DEMOCRATS GET BEHIND.
BERNIE HAS A CROWD, BIDEN DOES
NOT.
MARTY KNOWS WHAT STATES HE IS
IN, BUT IT DOES NOT.
>> Laura: I THINK THAT DEBATE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
COUNTRY TO HAVE.
THESE KIDS ARE GETTING TAUGHT
ABOUT COLLECTIVISM AND SOCIALISM
AND OF THE WONDERS OF SWEDEN AND
FRANCE.
IF WE ONLY DID SOCIALISM RIGHT
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
THIS IS WHAT THEY’RE BEING
TAUGHT.
IT IS TIME WE HAD THIS DEBATE
ONCE AND FOR ALL AND I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THEM DEBATE THAT.
THE WONDERS OF SOCIALISM VERSUS
THE POWER OF THE TRUMP ECONOMY.
THAT IS NECESSARY.
>> I THINK IT’S SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN BREWING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING WITH CONGRESS, TO
FIGHT ABOUT TO HAPPEN AND WE
OUGHT TO HAVE IT.
WE BETTER MAKE SURE WE WIN IT.
>> Laura: BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN
MANAGER, OR SPOKESWOMAN, KATIE
BEDINGFIELD WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
OBAMA ENDORSEMENT.
IS IT COMING?
DOES IT MATTER?
THIS IS HOW SHE TRIES TO ANSWER.
>> IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
DISAPPOINTED HE HASN’T GOT THAT
PUBLIC SHOW OF SUPPORT FROM
BARACK OBAMA?
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
HE SAID HE DIDN’T WANT TO IT.
HE DIDN’T THINK THAT WAS RIGHT
IN THAT COMING OUT OF THE GATE
HE NEEDED TO EARN THIS ON HIS
OWN MERIT.
>> THERE IS ONLY FOUR LEFT AND
HE STILL CAN’T DECIDE IF YOU
WILL ENDORSE JOE BIDEN.
IF THERE WAS ANY POWER TO THAT
ENDORSEMENT, IT WOULD’VE
HAPPENED TODAY.
IT’S NOT GOING TO MATTER
ANYMORE.
WHAT YOU FIND WITH OBAMA, HE
SEES THAT BERNIE IS GOING TO WIN
THIS THING.
HE HAS THE MOMENTUM.
THIS IS WHERE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS MOVED.
LOOK AT HOW MANY POLITICS THEY
WANT TO PLAY.
WE HAVE A CORONAVIRUS, WE HAVE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT NANCY PELOSI
DID?
SHE WITHHELD THE BILL LAST WEEK.
SO THEY COULD RUN ADS AGAINST
SEVEN REPUBLICANS.
>> Laura: HOW MANY PEOPLE RAN
ADS AGAINST A CORONAVIRUS?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
THEY TOOK THE DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE, THEY SPENT
MONEY, WENT INTO THE SEVEN
REPUBLICAN SEATS TO CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THEM ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
INSTEAD OF PUTTING AMERICA
FIRST, SHE PUT POLITICS FIRST
AND HOW THE BILL.
>> Laura: SHE SAID LAST WEEK
THIS IS THE TIME FOR PARTIES TO
COME TOGETHER?
>> SHE HAS POLITICS ALL THE
TIME.
THINK OF THIS, ALL OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
LAST WEEK TO DENOUNCE WHAT
BERNIE SAID ABOUT CUBA, NOT ONE
OF THEM VOTED AGAINST WHAT HE
SAID.
>> Laura: OBAMA IS SMART.
HE’S NOT GOING TO JUMP ON THIS
GRENADE.
IF HIS POLICIES WERE SO SMART,
HILLARY WOULD’VE WON IN 2016.
IF THEY LIKE OBAMA THE MAN, THE
PERSONALITY, BECAUSE HE’S COOL.
I DON’T THINK THE POLICIES ENDED
UP BEING AS POPULAR AS THE MAN.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MAGIC
WAND.